in brasilien brändle ringwald so viel
wie nie zuvor und schon ziemlich lange
hauptgrund brandrodung um anbauflächen
vor allem für soja zu gewinnen
geschrotet landet das auch in den trögen
unserer rinder schweine und hühner
billig futter aus brasilien für
billigfleisch aus deutschland jedes 69
cent kotelett fach die feuer an
flankiert durch eine miserable eu
agrarpolitik nach dem motto masse statt
qualität subventionen gibt es vor allem
für die die im großen stil produzieren
seit vielen jahren gegenstand heftigster
kritik vor allem aus den reihen der
umweltverbände und es wird schlimmer
denn wenn noch mehr soja angebaut wird
fallen die preise und das bedeutet der
hunger nach weiteren agrarflächen steigt
ein teufelskreis der seit jahrzehnten
hätte durchbrochen werden können 1992
rio de janeiro die un konferenz für
umwelt und entwicklung bringt auch die
erklärung zum internationalen schutz der
wälder hervor viel zu unverbindlich
wirkungslos ein polit flott vor allem
weil die industrieländer keine
wirklichen angebote gemacht haben wie
denn ein regenwald in wert zu setzen ist
denn wenn es sich in amazonien um die
grüne lunge der erde handelt dann müssen
deren leistungen als co2 senke und
sauerstoff lieferant bezahlt werden eben
auch von uns ausreichende konzepte dazu
sind bisher nicht zustande gekommen und
deswegen brennt er in der südamerika
nicht nur der regenwald ab wenn sich die
rauchschwaden verzogen haben wird der
erschreckende blick frei auf das
jahrzehntelange versagen internationale
umwelt- und klimapolitik